well you can just see and hear the wind
here at the moment i hope you can hear
me over the howling of that wind we have
broken wind speeds here in gloucester
off 60 miles an hour now but people are
being warm that this may not
yet be the worst of it they're being
told to expect their wind speeds up here
could reach 80 miles an hour
or even more people are being told there
is a risk to life here from falling
debris things like trees being blown
over power lines uh and the like and
there is also a severe risk of flooding
right here where we are in broad over
the waters of ten areas this morning
that have been given that severe uh
flood risk and the problem that they
think is going to be there's a tidal
surge coming at the moment
on the river seven here you might be
able to see the river levels uh just
behind me are very high here at the
moment and in combination with these
high winds uh they think that it could
mean the river will break its banks i'm
standing right now on the platform i'm
standing on here is actually a flood
defense the platform and the war just
along here were built as a blood defense
system 40 years ago and locals around
here have told me the water has not come
over these walls since it was built but
they've been told it could be a very
different story uh today the river
levels as i'm saying are already very
very high here and you can just see how
strong the wind is here we know the fire
brigade are on standby to help people
out they do get caught in the flooding
they were told last night to leave their
homes but many people are out who did
not heed that warning and they decided
to stay there are respite centers also
being set up if people do get caught in
these high winds and these floodings and
the flooding uh but the the advice
really is to be extremely careful if you
are around these areas and do not travel
unless it is absolutely necessary
katie for now thank you take care where
you are